my boy's four and a half can I ask you a
parenting question please how did you
keep him alive
my kid is just you know well boys they
are rough and tumble like girls have a
whole other set of like things to
contend with and issues but little boys
yeah I don't know how we keep them alive
I know he's pretty he I talked to him
yesterday he's he says he likes to say
poop all the time now
um and then last night was a beautiful
and I called him on FaceTime and um I
said he's not admit you did and I said
go go out I was on the balcony I said go
outside look at the Moon son and he went
outside the blood moon he was beautiful
right and I said go look at him I said
you see that Moon he said yeah Dad I
said that's the same Moon that I'm
looking at right now and he said I can
see your eyes dad and I said I could see
your eyes too son it was like this very
touching moment and I said I love you
Billy he said I love you poopy